ne sont pas limités seulement au sud-ouest des États-Unis.
En 2007, Brisbane, 3ème plus grande ville australienne,
en est arrivée à n'avoir plus que 6 mois d'eau potable.
Au Brésil, São Paulo est en train de vivre le même drame aujourd'hui,
le réservoir principal de la ville est passé de complètement plein en 2010,
à presque vide aujourd'hui
alors que la ville s'apprête à accueillir les les Jeux Olympiques de 2016.
Ceux d'entre nous qui ont la chance
de vivre dans une des plus grandes villes du monde
n'ont jamais vraiment vécu les effets d'une sécheresse catastrophique.
Nous nous plaignons de devoir raccourcir nos douches.
Nous montrons nos voitures sales et nos pelouses brunies.
Mais nous n'avons jamais pensé qu'un jour,
on tournerait le robinet et qu'il n'en sortirait rien.
C'est parce qu'à chaque fois que les choses ont mal tourné,
nous avons toujours pu agrandir un réservoir
ou creuser quelques puits supplémentaires.
Toutes les ressources en eau sont maintenant utilisées.
Nous ne pouvons plus compter sur cette bonne vieille façon
d'obtenir notre eau.
Certains pensent résoudre le problème de l'eau en ville
en prenant l'eau de nos voisins à la campagne.
Mais c'est une approche remplie de risques politiques, légaux et sociaux.
Même si nous réussissions à prendre l'eau de nos voisins,
nous ne faisons que transférer le problème sur quelqu'un d'autre
et il y a beaucoup de chances que cela se retourne contre nous :
un prix alimentaire plus élevé
et des dégâts sur l'écosystème marin qui a besoin de cette eau.
Je pense qu'il existe un meilleur moyen pour régler la crise de l'eau en ville
et je pense que c'est d'ouvrir 4 nouvelles sources locales d'eau
que je compare à des robinets.
Si nous arrivons à investir intelligemment dans ces nouvelles sources
dans les années qui arrivent, nous pourrons résoudre
notre problème d'eau en ville et réduire le risque de devoir un jour
faire face aux conséquences d'une sécheresse catastrophique.
Il y a 20 ans, si vous m'aviez dit
qu'une ville moderne pourrait exister sans importer d'eau,
je vous aurais pris pour un rêveur irréaliste et mal informé.
Mais mon expérience de ces dernières décennies
à travailler avec certaines des villes les plus sèches du monde
m'a montré que nous avons les technologies et les connaissances
pour réellement en finir avec l'eau importée
et c'est de cela dont je veux vous parler ce soir.
La 1ère source d'eau locale
que nous devons développer pour régler ce problème
vient de l'eau de pluie qui tombe sur nos villes.
L'une des plus grandes tragédies du développement urbain
est que, lorsque nos villes ont grandi,
nous avons recouvert le sol de béton et d'asphalte.
Ensuite, nous avons dû construire des égouts
pour évacuer l'eau de pluie qui tombait sur les villes
pour empêcher les inondations.
C'est un gâchis d'une ressource d'eau vitale et précieuse.
Prenez cet exemple :
ce graphique représente le volume d'eau
que la ville de San Jose pourrait collecter
si elle récupérait l'eau de pluie tombée sur son territoire.
L'intersection de la ligne bleue et des pointillés noirs indique
que si San Jose récupérait seulement la moitié de l'eau de pluie de sa ville,
la ville aurait assez d'eau pour une année complète.
Certains d'entre vous se disent probablement :
« La réponse à notre problème
est de commencer à construire de gros réservoirs
et de les attacher aux descentes de gouttières
pour récolter l'eau de pluie. »
Cette idée pourrait fonctionner à certains endroits.
Mais dans les villes, où il pleut majoritairement en hiver
et où la plupart de la demande en eau est en été,
ce n'est pas un moyen très économique pour résoudre notre problème en eau.
Et dans le cas d'une sécheresse qui dure depuis des années,
comme c'est le cas en ce moment en Californie,
aucun réservoir ne sera assez grand pour résoudre le problème.
Il existe une solution bien plus pratique
pour collecter les eaux de pluie qui tombent sur nos villes.
Il s'agit de la collecter et de la laisser s'infiltrer dans le sol.
La plupart de nos villes sont situées au dessus d'un réservoir naturel d'eau
capable d'accueillir d'énormes volumes d'eau.
Historiquement, Los Angeles obtenait un tiers de son eau d'un énorme aquifère
situé sous la vallée de San Fernando.
Imaginez l'eau qui tombe de votre toit,
coule sur votre pelouse et dans vos gouttières,
vous vous dites peut-être : « Est-ce que j'ai vraiment envie de boire ça ? »
La réponse, c'est que vous ne devriez pas la boire
tant qu'elle n'a pas été traitée.
Donc le défi de la collecte d'eau en ville
est de la collecter, de la traiter, et de l'acheminer sous terre.
C'est exactement ce que Los Angeles est en train de faire
avec un nouveau projet qui se construit à Burbank, en Californie.
Voici le complexe de réservoirs qu'ils sont en train de construire
en connectant des égouts et systèmes d'évacuation d'eaux pluviales
pour diriger cette eau vers une carrière abandonnée.
L'eau collectée dans cette carrière
passe lentement dans des zones humides créées par l'homme
puis elle arrive dans un terrain
où elle s'infiltre dans le sol
et remplit l'aquifère d'eau potable de la ville.
Lorsque l'eau passe dans la zone humide
et s'infiltre dans le sol,
elle rencontre des microbes qui vivent à la surface des plantes
et à la surface du sol,
ce qui purifie l'eau.
Et si l'eau n'est pas encore tout à fait potable
après être passée par ce procédé de traitement naturel,
la ville peut la traiter à nouveau
lorsqu'elle la pompe de l'aquifère,
avant de la rendre disponible au public.
Le 2ème robinet que nous devons ouvrir
pour résoudre notre problème d'eau en ville est celui des eaux usées
qui proviennent des stations d'épuration.
Beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent le concept d'eau recyclée.
Vous avez probablement déjà vu ces panneaux
indiquant que les massifs, les terre-pleins d'autoroute
et le terrain de golf
sont irrigués avec de l'eau
provenant d'une station d'épuration.
On utilise ce procédé depuis 20 ans déjà.
Mais l'expérience nous a appris
que cette approche est beaucoup plus onéreuse que ce qui était prévu.
Car une fois construits les premiers systèmes de recyclage d'eau
près des stations d'épuration,
la tuyauterie doit s'étendre elle aussi
pour amener l'eau à destination.
Et le coût devient prohibitif.
Nous avons découvert
qu'il est bien plus rentable et pratique de transformer
l'eau des stations d'épuration en eau potable,
en suivant deux étapes.
Première étape : mettre l'eau sous pression
et la faire passer à travers une membrane d'osmose inverse,
une membrane plastique fine et perméable
qui laisse passer les molécules d'eau
et filtre les sels, virus et autres produits organiques
potentiellement présents dans les eaux usées.
La deuxième étape du procédé :
on ajoute une petite quantité de peroxyde d'hydrogène
et on passe l'eau à la lumière ultraviolette.
La lumière ultraviolette dissocie le peroxyde d'hydrogène
en deux parties appelées radicaux hydroxyles.
Et ces radicaux hydroxyles sont une forme très puissante d'oxygène,
capables de dissoudre la plupart des produits chimiques organiques.
Après avoir suivi ces deux étapes,
l'eau devient potable.
J'en connais un rayon, j'ai étudié l'eau recyclée
en utilisant toutes les techniques de mesure connues
pendant les 15 dernières années.
On a découvert certains composés
qui peuvent passer la première étape du procédé,
mais après la seconde, le procédé d'oxydation avancée,
les produits chimiques résistent rarement.
C'est très différent des réserves d'eau que l'on tient pour acquises
et d'où l'on boit quotidiennement.
Il existe une autre méthode pour recycler de l'eau.
Voici une zone de recyclage
récemment construite près de la rivière Santa Ana, en Californie du sud.
Cette zone de recyclage reçoit de l'eau d'une partie de la rivière Santa Ana
qui, pendant l'été, n'est presque que des eaux usées
qui proviennent d'autres villes comme Riverside et San Bernardino.
L'eau arrive dans la zone de traitement,
elle est exposée au soleil et aux algues,
ces algues cassent les produits chimiques organiques,
retirent les nutriments et désactivent les agents pathogènes flottants.
L'eau retourne ensuite dans la rivière Santa Ana,
et coule jusqu'à Anaheim, pour y être prélevée
et s'infiltrer dans le sol pour devenir l'eau potable de Anaheim,
terminant son voyage depuis les égouts de Riverside County
jusqu'aux réserves d'eau potable d'Orange County.
Vous pensez peut-être que cette idée de boire l'eau recyclée des eaux usées
est un fantasme futuriste ou que c'est peu courant.
En Californie, on recycle déjà
près de 150 milliards de litres d'eau usées
selon le processus en deux étapes dont j'ai parlé.
C'est une quantité suffisante pour subvenir aux besoins
d'un million de personnes sans autre accès à l'eau.
Le 3ème robinet que nous devons ouvrir n'est pas un robinet du tout.
C'est un genre de robinet virtuel, il s'agit juste d'économiser l'eau.
Nous devons économiser plus d'eau, en particulier en extérieur,
car en Californie et dans d'autres villes américaines,
près de la moitié de notre consommation d'eau a lieu à l'extérieur.
Avec la sécheresse actuelle, nous avons vu qu'il était possible
que nos pelouses et nos jardins survivent avec moitié moins d'eau.
Donc pas besoin de se mettre à peindre le béton en vert,
ni de tout recouvrir de gazon artificiel ou d'acheter des cactus.
On peut avoir un paysage adapté à la Californie
avec des détecteurs d'humidité du sol et des systèmes d'irrigation intelligents
et avoir de beaux espaces verts dans nos villes.
Le 4ème et dernier robinet que nous devons ouvrir
pour résoudre notre problème d'eau en ville
consiste à dessaler l'eau de mer.
Je sais ce que vous avez déjà dû entendre à ce sujet :
« C'est génial si on a des tonnes de pétrole, pas beaucoup d'eau
et peu de scrupules vis-à-vis du réchauffement climatique. »
Dessaler l'eau de mer est très énergivore, quelle que soit la méthode adoptée.
Mais dire que cette pratique est vouée à l'échec est une critique obsolète.
Nous avons fait d'énormes progrès sur le dessalement de l'eau de mer
ces 20 dernières années.
Cette image montre
la plus grosse usine occidentale de dessalement,
actuellement en construction au nord de San Diego.
Comparée à l'usine de Santa Barbara construite il y a 25 ans,
cette usine utilisera environ la moitié de l'énergie de l'ancienne
pour produire un litre d'eau.
Mais ce n'est pas parce que cette méthode est devenue moins énergivore
qu'il faut construire ce genre d'usines partout.
Parmi les solutions à notre disposition, c'est probablement
la plus gourmande en énergie et potentiellement la plus polluante
de toutes les options pour créer des réserves en eaux locales.
Alors voilà,
grâce à ces 4 sources d'eau,
nous pouvons arrêter de dépendre de l'eau importée.
En modifiant la manière dont nous aménageons notre urbanisme,
nous pouvons réduire notre consommation d'eau en extérieur de 50 %
et ainsi augmenter nos réserves en eau de 25 %.
Nous pouvons recycler l'eau des égouts
et ainsi augmenter nos réserves en eau de 40 %.
Et nous pouvons trouver la différence avec une combinaison
de récolte de l'eau de pluie et de dessalement.
Ensemble, créons nos réserves d'eau pour qu'elles puissent faire face
aux défis du réchauffement climatique des années à venir.
Faisons en sorte que nos réserves en eau soient alimentées localement,
laissent assez d'eau pour l'environnement, les poissons et l'agriculture.
Créons un réseau hydraulique respectant nos valeurs environnementales.
Faisons-le pour nos enfants et nos petits-enfants
et disons-leur que c'est le système dont ils doivent prendre soin
car c'est notre dernière chance de réinventer notre rapport à l'eau.
Merci de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)